throughout the donald trump presidency i
would often jokingly say whatever
happened to that migrant caravan coming
to the united states border from mexico
and of course it was a joke referencing
the completely capricious and arbitrary
nature of how the trump republican party
and republicans more broadly
go back to the same refrains when it's
convenient for them
trump had a crazy phone call with
ukraine well it's infrastructure week at
the white house republicans propose an
insane
health care plan that would lead to 24
million people losing coverage
well the migrant caravan is coming and
democrats don't care
laura ingram literally ran a segment
yesterday called joe biden's
insurrection
yeah i know donald trump's second
impeachment trial starts today
because he incited the january sixth
insurrection
yes joe biden has a higher approval
rating already than donald trump
ever did during his entire presidency
yes
republicans are standing in opposition
to a coveted relief bill that's popular
with the majority of the country yes
the majority of americans wants donald
trump convicted so it's time
for biden's insurrection
let's um take a look at these clips
which as
laura ingram will explain to us is joe
biden
welcoming undocumented immigrants to the
united states
let's check out the clips fox news
apparently realizing they need to
out crazy oan and newsmax to get back
some of the audience that they've lost
now that takes us back to tomorrow's
barnum bailey revival in the senate
democrats are arguing that trump
welcomed and incited
a violent incursion into the capital
when it is they who are enticing
illegals
to bust through our borders exploit our
resources
and commit crimes and we're not talking
about a few hundred
we're talking hundreds of thousands
eventually millions
if the democrats have their way even for
fox news this is really a stretch
at this point i don't even know if the
fox news audience
believes this at least not a huge
portion of it but
some of them do let's listen to some
more and she really crams in
a lot of hate xenophobia misdirection
red herrings into this one short clip
there is an insurrection taking place
against america all right
it's been going on for years in the
deepest depth of the dc swamp
and now its figurehead resides at 1600
pennsylvania avenue
this insurrection seeks to overthrow
everything we love about america
by defaming it silencing it and even
prosecuting it
this is an organized mob funded by
billionaires
it's supported by celebrities and it's
aided and abetted by propagandistic news
organizations
every single step of the way
these insurrectionists have stormed our
schools with blm
indoctrinators they shuttered our
classrooms by empowering union heavies
they've overwhelmed small businesses
with idiotic
stupid lockdowns they've robbed
americans of good paying oil and gas
jobs
with obscene climate change dictates
they've ripped down historical markers
from washington
to lincoln they've terrorized patriotic
americans
who are now afraid to just speak their
minds
they burn police precincts they've taken
over entire city blocks
and not just for a few hours by the way
but for weeks
this is the sort of brown people are
going to take your house
portion of laura ingraham's program
and um this is actually a lot of what
these faux populists are right-wing
populists where
they sort of sound like populists but
their solutions are bonkers often they
end up at black lives matter will take
your house brown people will take your
job sort of stuff
and in that short clip black lives
matter is bad mexican immigrants are bad
liberal celebrities are bad covet
guidelines are bad
getting away with fossil getting away
from fossil fuels is bad
climate change is fake confederate
monuments are good
and it's so heavily weaponized
that it's difficult to believe that it's
even real i mean it looks like an
snl skit of a fox news show
if fox news decided to run a test where
they said
let's test our audience to see
what's the dumbest and craziest thing we
can
get them to believe how about this let's
pretend joe biden is leading an
insurrection
this is what that test would look like
and
we've seen you know we wondered a month
ago what would a post-trump fox news
look like
fox news no longer covers coveted
briefings which are happening by the way
fox news rarely covers white house press
briefings
which are happening and it's this type
of stuff now
fighting for the most extreme audience
they can and there's a real question as
to whether they believe
that that is the audience they need to
be profitable
in other words if what they were losing
to oan and newsmax
were not a particularly profitable piece
of their audience
they wouldn't necessarily need to be
doing this to get that audience back but
they're doing it and there must be a
reason for it and of course the really
scary
part is that you and i see this
we know every word is a lie it's it's
like
when it was the migrant caravan during
the trump era right
it's all made up it's all fake
there are millions of people in this
country though where you sit them
down and you show them that commentary
from laura ingram
and they believe it and they think that
forget about they think it's good
reporting they think it's reporting
uh rather than just the rantings of uh
of laura ingram
and it's a systemic problem and when we
talk about i i don't want to do my whole
rant now but
when we talk about epistemology when we
talk about media literacy when we talk
about
identifying logical fallacies and
distinguishing between
statements of fact and statements of
opinion opinion programming news
programming all of these things
the net effect is laura ingraham does
that
and a lot of people come away thinking i
have now been informed by a news report
which is of course the furthest thing
from what that actually was